bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
siamo tornati i suoi più visto ragazzi
sono sono contentissimo veramente
contento per il fatto che tipo una
settimana fa c'era un dibattito pazzesco
perché non si sapeva se è più il doveva
chiudere non so perché è invece ragazzi
non ha chiuso era soltanto una voce
della minkia e meno male perché non
potevo non potevo sopportare di
abbandonare di duke ai figli ragazzine
di festeggiare partendo subito chi se ne
fotte
sono veramente contento giorno perché
non posso stare senza è che sappiate
pazienza dei partners partiamo col primo
no perché c'è il papà di uk con non per
fermo cazzo chi è che stava prima donna
che salvataggio giorno ok ragazzi mi
sono salvato in tuffo harmen se tu vada
ragazzini importante che siamo partiti
da dio come in ogni punta se tu mi stai
dicendo che non sono riuscita a toccare
il traguardo mi sono affatto dei
chilometri più praticamente qualche
merda si porca [ __ ] elin traguardo non
è così si ok ho perso il casco ma non me
ne frega niente finché sono un serpente
della madonna che figo è ma che figo è
io so parlare serpente se voi non lo
sapete ma so parlare il serpente se gli
ho detto che li puzza culo ragazzi io
non ho mai visto il cazzo di salvezze
faresti trick tra l'altro non so con che
criterio si sta muovendo perché c'erano
ciò che mi sfida dove va il nonno fermo
ti dirò mangiarli stravers perfetto
varda li guardo e questa è la mia
colazione non mi sa che non riesco a
mangiare le gambe si no le mie gambe
[ __ ] quell'ala mio pranzo e
tristissimo vederlo muovere così sembra
così chi sono questi ma eccolo eccolo
ecco dov'è ecco perfetto ma ieri qui
stronzo che non ho fatto merenda vieni
ti va bene comunque bello beh se lo
pensassi
lo pensa lo besa se lo spreco lo qui
ecco lo spuntino ce l'abbiamo fatta dopo
anni a mangiare qualcosa ma è possibile
tanto succulento uomo di cioccolato
vieni qui underworld mica stiamo
entrando nel sottosuolo è normale questo
in un giallo
no no perché cazzo cioè io un paio di
ali uccidi il ladro cd ladro lo faccio
subito perché non mi piace non mi piace
io ho un tavolo e non ho paura di osare
come non detto allora farmi di provare
un attimo perché in teoria dovrebbe
essere questa l'arma questo sarebbe
ladro chi cazzella lo fatevi capire che
non ho capito cosa fai non perché sta
accadendo così non è un televisore un
televisore o una freccia nel naso
fantastico no perché non capita anche
che cosa sto facendo quello per che
ricadono le macchine ad hoc
qual è lo scopo di sto livello a1 più
mio piega vinto per mark set flight che
cazzo si no che figata nove ragazzi
questa è una figata
aspettate fatevi prendere prima sto
tizio che mi sembra messo malissimo
perfetto va a fan culo merda ragazzi
siamo attaccati da un braccio non so se
norma fermi non toccarmi bene metti
intellettuale manina il culo stronzo
guarda io ho una gamma una gamba
permetto una gamba e un braccio nel culo
non temi vivai montina che mi servi
stronzo sono miei ormai fuori bastardo
se ti prenda parte striscia di merda
però
[Musica]
lasciamo perdere il suo livello capace
fino alla sede olympics è meglio così
ecco cosa fare
queste sono limpidi più belle che io
abbia mai visto
allora devo prendere stop non ce la farò
mai aprendo non so che neanche che cos'è
a perfetti intero che cazzo ne so devo
mettermi qui sopra cosa sta facendo
perché a queste di nuovo alla gara di
nuoto
io non ho mai visto una persona nuotare
così non solo ai ragazzi importante che
siamo arrivati i primi poi chissenefrega
questa è la gara del lancio del mondo
ciak si curano prefetto vinto ragazzi
ultimamente più gioca a demis più mi
chiedo perché perché solo perché non so
neanche perché cosa solo perché c'è una
cosa sparati sto è già che mira che
mirate alla madonna
no effettivamente ragazzi non pensavo di
prenderlo juno però l'ho preso
importante è quello poi quando devo
andare di qua
l'onda di giorno togliti
oggi non c'è verso lega non c'è verso
sono un fenomeno ultras by fa
addirittura oltre che cazzo e no vabbè
io di questi non fatti un miliardo
quindi non pensare di fottermi come se
vole guardalo nemica che salto all
altolà sudore ed e noi cosa non fatemi
capire se ci sia un cazzo impossibile
questo che salti in su si fa e di mai
norma ci ha spiegato ma si sono vivo
no non sono vivo casa sono così
stringenti spingi spingi come non è mai
fatto neanche la mattina quando cagiva
[ __ ] cazzo mica che culo che culo
assurda tratto sono anche morto c'è come
ha fatto a vincere che sono sono più a
pezzi che altro ragazzi migliori
comporre mentre il cola si va beh ma che
casa devo lanciare allagamento della
coca cola
l'importante è riuscire a beccare va
bene un sollecito manca prenderla casa
vediamo se riesco a farlo non è così
e il livello piu difficile che abbia mai
giocato non si può peccare dunque da lì
che merce non riesco a beccare marraffa
ancora c'è massimo scattato ha fatto di
ho fatto gli impossible
ho fatto lì spy phone e non riesco a
beccare una cazzo di zen se lo preva
backed isae la madonna e la madonna
questa sarebbe una bolla di coca cola
cioè normale che camp nou fermi oddio se
pezza da digerire sta casa ce ne vuole
porca [ __ ] webster weapons test vai
così dove dovete stare delle armi e la
madonna ragazzi ma che violenza e vabbè
ma esageratissimo c'è ma sto coso 6 sul
burp e non è allora no no non tutti a
lecce non toccare che cioè allora sei
bastardo fatelo dire a cap a 40 km
chi la sta usando nessuno cioè non è
normale ragazzi non ho mai giocato un
livello così violento non aveva sermas
machete trovo lanciani machete
[ __ ] becca tra le in testa ed
ancora che ormai già oggi c'è una mira
che è meglio non fidarvi io lo dico
allora vediamo nelle tette non è le
tette no o forse sì o forse no o forse
sì o forse sono un [ __ ] angry mob e
mode si va bene insomma come legge
ragazzi olga l'attuale donna e gilda ha
ucciso una pec una pecora
pagherei per questo ho ucciso la pecora
gava vede sono prese che capitano mi
dispiace ho guardato anche uccidendo dei
poveri delle povere angurie e anche una
zucca non scherzava scatta nostra ce la
posso fare
sì se non ci posso credere di esserci
riuscito ma ci arrivano fino qua no kat
sono caduto non sono perfetto sono
ovunque sono fottutamente ovunque
mica ho mancato un look campi sta
stancando di correre ho bisogno di un po
d'acqua perché non è perché queste
persone non mi perdonano
e che ne so ecco un po d'acqua grazie
mille è questa io c'ho anche un pezzo di
anguria e non te la pago grazie no no
fermo no kat
ma allora sei stronzo ma perché
l'elicottero epic questo devo farle p66
vai vai con steve che ancora non lo sa
ed è in queste situazioni che capisci di
essere nella merda non avevo dubbio di
mette l'ansia misura una cosa pazzesca
allora ti devi togliere a chi david o ma
se c'è solo assurdo che culo assurdo c'è
mamma voi avete mai visto avete mai
visto un boltro dove devi lanciare dei
beni dei dei peni che una cosa fate una
mina cazzo sono apparsi dei beni più
grossi
non è normale che non lo so perché ma
poi perché credo che debba fare centra
c'è scritto anche win
perfetto allora non è così gp [ __ ] di
merda ragazzi ma che poi perché devo
lanciare un pene in un secchio in poche
parole un penny non sei chiudere
sì ho visto il bene nel secchio
ma chi è questa la cosa più bella di
bersi una birra e guardare la propria
donna è una gatta ma questa questa è
vuota mi hai dato una bottiglia vuota a
questo però funziona forse a vj's
helicopter cos'è una nota
mio dio mio dio no fermi ragazzi sta
cosa epico sto cosa è fottutamente come
si fa è la gara fatemi andare
fatemi andare un cazzo sono diventato un
unicorno ma perché ragazzi non si può
fare abbiate pazienza che l'avevamo
fatto ragazzi che cazzo di slalom fatto
non ne ho idea
non mi chiedete corpus e qui e credo
andare avanti dico a tornare indietro
come cazzo fate incastra jeanine cast no
oddio è un mutaforma
si allunga così no ma cazzo perso vabbè
lo sapevo che ha voglia di andare
sull'elicottero si perde la testa ora
lasciamo perdere
noi ha concluso il vile episodio nove
ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto sotto il
commento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e comuni video trovate nella
descrizione serve per i siti iscrivetevi
ci rivediamo in un prossimo video belle
ragazze